hallo leute wir haben heute besuch von
einer aus kasachstan willkommen in
berlin
danke schön ich freue mich sehr wir
stellen euch heute ein neues wort im
deutschen vor und dieses wort heißt na
ja los geht's
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was bedeutet der auszug naja was
bedeutet so viel wie ist okay naja es ja
sie ja wenn man etwas nicht so ganz
genau weiß und sagt man erstmal ja ja ja
ja
nicht nein und nicht ja nur wasser
zwischen zürich und wann genau man das
wort naja
wenn es wenn was nicht so gut ist aber
auch nicht so schlecht
vielleicht was bedeutet der ausdruck
naja eine mischung aus ja und nein
na ja das ist so es ist nicht ja es ist
nicht nein das ist ja ja ja ja ist eine
interaktion also ein ausruf wort mit
einer interaktion kann man eine stimmung
ausdrücken
viele leute haben gesagt dass naja
zwischen ja und nein liegt und
tatsächlich drückt man mit naja zweifel
aus wenn man zum beispiel eine frage
stellt und man antwortet mit naja dann
sagt man damit dass man nicht wirklich
zustimmt aber die aussage auch nicht
komplett ablehnt ich kann sehr gut
singen
naja in berlin ist das wetter immer
schön ja ja ja ja bedeutet so viel wie
vielleicht mal schauen wer weiß so etwas
was man wage ausdrücken möchte oder was
man noch nicht weiter sagt man einfach
na ja das wetter ist echt beschissen
wollte naja was will man machen
mit nayar kann man eine aussage
relativieren
das heißt man setzt etwas in eine
perspektive man gibt sozusagen ein
gegenargument etwas ist entweder nicht
so schlecht
oder eben nicht so gut schmeckt ihr das
essen naja wie findest du sehe ich in
einem kleid aus naja maxime einen neuen
freund na ja so was in die richtung
naja heißt ja aber nicht richtig ja
also was abwägen ist naja kann man
machen muss man nicht so wenn man
versuchen würde
naja mit einer geste auszudrücken dann
würde ich am ehesten einfach die
schulterzucken
naja kennen sie ein paar beispiele geben
wenn sie mich fragen wie geht es ihnen
leute dann kann ich antworten na ja es
heißt wieder gut noch schlecht
naja oder wenn man sich verabredet hat
und der eine kommt zu spät und dann sagt
der entschuldigung und dann sagt man ja
ja nicht so schlimm
genau und oder weißt du jetzt was maja
bedeutet naja eigentlich schon und ich
habe viele nette leute kennengelernt und
das war eine tolle erfahrung dankeschön
das freut mich sehr wir hoffen dass ihr
jetzt auch wisst rus naja bedeutet und
wenn ihr noch mehr deutsch lernen möchte
dann empfehlen wir euch unbedingt unsere
apps
dort könnt ihr nämlich das deutsche
vokabular lernen mit einem
vokabeltrainer und in unserer apps haben
wir seit kurzem auch übersetzungen in
andere sprachen dank unserer community
also euch haben wir mittlerweile das
deutsche roca wohl auch in andere
sprachen übersetzt nämlich nicht nur
englisch sondern auch russisch arabisch
spanisch portugiesisch und es gibt dort
viele übersetzung guckt euch das mal an
wir freuen uns wenn ihr sie länger
ausprobiert danke dass du zu besuch ist
und wir sehen uns schon nächste woche
wieder
[Musik]